hey what's up guys I'm Kim BHD here and
welcome to your first look at Google's
first foldable phone it's almost wild
that it's finally here and I got to hold
it and play with it for the first time
after all these months of rumors and
hype so the phone is exactly what it
sounds like it's a pixel with a folding
screen on the inside and we are curious
just waiting to see what it would look
like just because this is the official
Google take on what a folding Android
phone would look like so now we've got
it so for a phone like this there's
basically three categories that matter
design hardware specs and software
and I guess also probably price but
we'll get to that at the end because
that's also important it's an expensive
phone but with my like hours of Hands-On
time with the phone I did get a pretty
good sense of all three of these things
so for Design This is a more compact
folding phone I would say it's in the
same style as the Oppo Find N2 but a
little bigger and a little thinner so
there's a 5.8 inch OLED display on the
outside pretty thin bezels power button
and fingerprint reader and volume
buttons on the side and there's a pretty
firm hinge that can stop at just about
any angle to hold the phone open for
easel mode but then this is where it
gets interesting Google made a pretty
big design choice in the hinge mechanism
to put a lot of the parts of the folding
Hardware above and below the middle
instead of behind it so that's what
makes the hinge itself and the entire
phone so thin but that also means
there's extra Hardware now above and
below the hinge so when you open up the
phone yes that means there's a bit more
bezel than usual above and below the
display now it's a pretty generous 7.6
inch display unfolding on the inside
here but I think that it it'll be
slightly controversial because people
are going to freak out about the bezels
that's like one of the things you can
count on for the internet but honestly
looking at it and using it I'm totally
fine with it like it lets them put an
actually good front facing camera and
the bezel on the inside here and it
gives you a bit of something to hold on
to and rest your thumb when you're
holding the phone open anyway around the
back is the camera bar that doesn't
quite span the whole width of the back
but it still looks very pixel Plus on
the side there's an LED flash and a
microphone array and it comes in two
colors basically black and white
honestly I think it's a pretty good
looking phone I'm someone who liked the
looks of the older pixels so that falls
right in line with that and I keep going
back to this Oppo Find N2 this is a
phone whose form factor I've loved so
much and the pixel is both a little
bigger and a little thinner which is
really interesting and we're gonna have
to see how this thinness trade-off pays
off because that naturally means not so
much battery right so let's we'll get to
the next category let's talk about the
next section of things which is just
hardware specs so the story of the
hardware here is a it's mostly Flagship
or just short of it so the 5.8 inch
display on the outside is a 1080p 120
hertz OLED with over 1500 nits Peak
brightness which is great and the 7.6
inch OLED on the inside is also 120
hertz it's also just over 1440p and this
6x5 aspect ratio I think these screens
are awesome but then on the inside
you've got tensor G2 which has been in
the pixel for several months now and 12
gigs of RAM and then there's a
4821 milliamp hour battery inside now
just for context that's an interesting
number 4800 that would make it the
largest battery we've ever seen in a
foldable but at the same time
uh the pixel 7 Pro has a 5000 milliamp
hour battery and the same tensor G2 and
average battery life I think we can say
and so having a smaller battery and a
much bigger brighter screen in this
pixel fold does give me some pause about
battery life that's that's a question uh
that I have to actually use it to find
out and review it but I think also
wireless charging good to see but it's
also kind of slow wired charging 30
Watts Max and then with the triple
cameras at the back there's actually all
new sensors throughout here which Google
says are Flagship grade but we're
definitely going to have to test these
out for the full review but we're
looking at a 48 megapixel main camera
then a 10 megapixel Ultra wide and a 10
megapixel 5x telephoto so overall as a
package teetering on Flagship but not
completely maxed out obviously you know
the displays I think looked really
really good in person super smooth super
bright and responsive but there are
clearly concerns I think the battery is
the big question in my head which is
always just going to be a combination of
physical capacity but also software
optimizations and so of course software
is a big part of what makes phone good
especially in a folding phone because
it's a phone and also a tablet at the
same time so this pixel fold is going to
have all the pixel stuff you know the
Google Assistant now playing hold for me
material U the customizable looking
version of Android that we've seen in
the pixels that make it the smartest
smartphone in the world and I love all
that but of course on the inside screen
we're talking about basically a tablet
and Android tablets let's be real have
always been a little bit lacking in a
software department so I was curious to
see if there was new stuff here and
there is some stuff to pay attention to
so first of all the expected stuff like
side-by-side multitasking feels really
smooth and intuitive the apps resize
however you want them but that's not new
what's new is this dock Behavior at the
bottom so you can now long press that
bar at the bottom of Android that's
normally for gestures and it brings up a
dock of apps which I think I need to
play with more to understand better but
I'm gonna guess it's your most recent
apps and it's not fully customizable but
we'll see either way you can quickly
launch and bounce around other apps here
and jump right into split screen
multitasking just like what Samsung did
with the permanent dock on the fold it's
just this one takes up less space and
also during my time with the phone I was
sort of talking with some people on
Google's team about it and they talked a
big game about optimization which I feel
like we hear this story a lot but
they've worked with a lot of developers
on optimizing tablet versions of their
apps to look good on the pixel fold
they're also launching a tablet so that
should help both devices and also
they've updated something like 50 Google
apps to all work on the larger display
whether that's a column layout or just
something that takes advantage of the
entire display instead of just looking
like a stretched phone version of the
app so I think good news on the software
TBD when we test it decent Hardware
overall and I think a pretty nice design
but then of course we should get to the
price which I mentioned at the beginning
I felt like it would kind of overshadow
the whole thing which is how crazy it is
but this phone will cost
1799 dollars
is an 1800 phone and 1800 bucks is a lot
for a phone that's at the top of the
market I'm pretty sure that's the exact
same price that Samsung's fold 4
launched at but now that's probably
dropped in price since it came out so I
mean we're this is going to bring
comparisons to every other 1800 folding
phone option so if I'm just guessing
from my first impressions this is going
to be a tough sell for anyone who isn't
specifically interested in the pixel
software experience which to be fair I'm
one of those people I love that but it's
the same tough cell that the pixel 7 Pro
was but at least this was sort of
undercutting some of the most expensive
like Ultra phones out there where this
pixel fold is the same price as the most
expensive best Flagship folding phones
but all in all very interesting very
interesting Google's first entry into
the folding phone space definitely get
subscribed to this channel so you can
see the full review when I actually get
my hands on this phone for a longer
period of time and test it but for now
that's your first look let me know what
you think is this gonna be able to sell
at this price or is this just another
one first option in the first gen pile
that people probably shouldn't buy let
me know what you think
thanks for watching
get to the next one peace
[Music]
foreign